ich habe etwas ziemlich verrücktes vor
und ihr müsst mir sagen ob ihr glaubt
dass das machbar ist in der nächsten 100
Tagen möchte ich nur das essen was ich
selber angebaut gesammelt gejagt oder
gefischt haben außerdem darf ich meine
selbst erzeugten Sachen mit anderen
Leuten die auch etwas selber gemacht
haben zu einem fairen Preis tauschen das
große Problem mein Gartenjahr war alles
andere als rosig im Garten ist quasi
keine Ernte mehr ich habe doch zwei
Beete Kartoffeln die ich noch nicht
geerntet habe Kartoffeln werden in so
einem Projekt extrem wichtig weil die
halt satt machen ich weiß aber nicht wie
die Ernte ausfällt es kann sein dass die
richtig schlecht ist weil der Sommer so
unfassbar trocken war das der Ernte
wurde von ungefähr 200 Ratten
aufgefressen die in meinem Garten leben
kein Witz kann ich euch gerne im
nächsten Video mal zeigen was glaubt ihr
ist das möglich oder werde ich
verhungern ist mir auch egal was ihr
sagt ich werde so oder so probieren also
wenn ihr Lust habt zu sehen ob ich es
schaffen werde dann folgt mir am
Mittwoch geht's nämlich los oh